in this video I want to talk about
allosteric regulation and it's a very
important form of enzyme regulation so
it's something that we should definitely
understand so allosteric regulation
literally means other allo means other
and then steric means shape so we'll see
how that sort of can help us remember
what allosteric enzymes are and what
allosteric regulation is keep this in
mind other shape so when we think about
also allosteric I kind of think other
site as well other shape or other site
allosteric enzymes are multi subunit
proteins whose activity is affected by
binding of other molecules which are
called effectors so let's think about
this for a second allosteric enzymes are
multi-subunit protein so if they're
multi-subunit protein something we
should know about them is that they are
they have quaternary structure that's
the highest level of protein structure
that they have and something we should
bear in mind so their activity is
affected by binding up other molecules
okay so so binding of molecules can
affect the activity of an allosteric
enzyme now specifically binding of an
effector which I'll go over in just a
second at one subunit has structural and
therefore functional effects or binding
of an effector at one subunit has
structural or functional effects on
other subunits and shortly I'll give you
sort of an example that kind of clears
things clears things up a little bit so
what is an allosteric effector the
simplest definition is that it's
anything that can bind to an allosteric
enzyme and alter its conformation or
function so let me get into these Homa
tropic and heterocyclic effects and kind
of bring up examples so
homo tropic effects are the definition
is sort of is binding of a substrate
which is often called the primary ligand
at one site affects the binding of that
same ligand at another site so example
of this an example of a homo tropic
effect is if we're thinking about
hemoglobin we think about hemoglobin and
oxygen if you recall oxygen binding
hemoglobin at one site right increases
the affinity for oxygen at the other
three sites if you recall that that idea
was called cooperativity and we
mentioned that cooperativity is a
particular type of allosteric regulation
so even more specifically it's a
homophobic effect because binding of
oxygen right which is the primary ligand
for hemoglobin at one site affects the
binding of that same ligand right oxygen
at other sites okay
so binding of oxygen at one site
increases the affinity for oxygen for
oxygen add those other three sites okay
so how is that different from
heterotrophic effects well
binding of a ligand different from the
primary ligand has an effect on the
enzymes affinity for the primary ligand
so if we want to keep hemoglobin as the
example then we can think about
hemoglobin and the other things that
could have bound it if you recall
protons or or carbon dioxide and 2 3 vpg
we talked about them as far as like the
Bohr effect goes and all of these right
h plus co 2 and 2 3 v PG they're all
ligands that are not primary ligand they
don't they're not oxygen they are not
the primary elegance for human bobbing
but they can bind hemoglobin right and
they have an effect on the enzymes
affinity for the primary ligand these
all affect o to affinity right
specifically they all decrease it right
which I'll get into in just a moment as
far as that makes them actually
allosteric inhibitors okay so so
allosteric enzymes have two
state that we think about okay so or two
confirmations there is the relaxed state
which is called the are state and there
is the T state also known as the tight
or taut state and I kind of drew this
here to kind of get at that idea in just
a second so what you should remember is
that the our state has a high affinity
for the substrate and the T or tight
state has a low affinity for the
substrate okay so let's think about this
one use this a little example here if we
think about if we think about this being
a particular allosteric enzyme it can
exist in this form here this
conformation or its structure will
slightly change I've kind of you know
made it look really really exaggerated
here if I think about these two portions
is here and this here as being active
sites okay then then I can think about
you know on to the different
polypeptides that are part of this
protein then this this here supposed to
be the active site in this here supposed
to be exercise if you can't already tell
I meant I meant this for B to be
considered the relaxed state or the our
state actually let me just write our
state instead of relaxed all the way out
so this is the our state right which has
a high affinity for the substrate and
this here is the T state which has a low
affinity for the substrate if we imagine
the substrate looking something like
like a square for instance okay if this
is the substrate then the substrate can
bind here it's kind of a squared area it
could bind there right you can see how
it would fit in there right and nicely
whereas here there's no way a square is
gonna fit in here without having some
sort of trouble okay so the our state
has a high affinity for the substrate
and the T state has a low affinity for
the substrate so let's ask ourselves
this question what would make sense if
if we added more substrate or increase
the substrate concentration that will
shift the equilibrium between the R and
T state so which two
will it shift it in well if there's more
substrate chances all we want the enzyme
to be more active right and have a high
affinity for the substrate okay
so so if we add substrate it'll shift
the equilibrium to the in this case
settle to the left which is of the our
state I could have written it backwards
and it would have shifted it to the
right but it still it would still be
shifting towards the our state so in
this case left right but the entirely
correct answer is towards the our state
and this makes sense because that's when
I actually go on a dimension here is
that the our state is the active state
and the T state is the inactive not on
active inactive state and that makes
sense right something has a high
affinity for the substrate it's gonna
you know bind the substrate and when
enzymes or proteins in general bind
their substrates they're going to react
somehow right which would be active okay
so so if we have a large substrate
concentration or if we increase the
substrate concentration we will shift
the enzyme state towards the our state
then therefore having it be more active
because if there's more substrate around
chances are we want that and like to be
more active and catalyze the reaction
for that particular substrate okay so
now within within you know these
effectors there are allosteric
activators and allosteric inhibitors
well if we know that the our state is
the active state and the T state is the
inactive state then what would you
expect an activator to stabilize it's
going to stabilize one of those states
so an activator would stabilize
hopefully you guessed it the our state
right because it's going to be active if
it wants to be active if it's going to
stabilize the our state which is the
state that binds the substrate that
makes sense that an activator would
stabilize it in the our state and sort
of keep the equilibrium at the our state
whereas if we don't want that enzyme to
be active we would want to inhibit its
function we would want it to be in the T
state so depending on what we want the
enzyme to do we're going to either
activate or inhibit it so activate
allosteric activators well
the RSA allosteric inhibitors will
stabilize the t-state and just as just
to mention again the reason we're
talking about all this is because we're
going to think about other different
enzymes in a bunch of different pathways
that we'll talk about in future videos
okay so I drew this um this this curve
here of velocity / / substrate
concentration and I kind of wanted to
mention something briefly and if we can
imagine this graph right notice how all
I have drawn this this uh this graph
here notice this is not this is not
hyperbolic right this is a sigmoidal
shape
okay so allosteric enzymes when they
have multiple subunits they have a
sigmoid alape let me actually write that
in pink so sigmoid 'el right or s shape
to the graph okay and so this is this
white line that I've drawn here this is
assuming that there is no activator or
no inhibitor so this the control okay
this white white line is the control so
notice here that the reaction velocity
at low substrate concentrations is low
right so that would be the T State okay
so here at low substrate concentrations
right here at low substrate
concentrations we would expect the the
sort of the T state in this area here
this would be a T state right because
the act the enzyme is not very active
but as we increase the substrate
concentration as we increase the
substrate concentration notice that our
reaction velocity increases okay so that
means that we're making the ACT enzyme
more active and if we're making it more
active or stabilizing the our state so
chances are as we're acting as we're
adding scuse me more substrate we're
stabilizing the our state somewhere up
here okay the more active state is the
our state so now why did I draw this red
line here and this blue line here well
if we can imagine this red line this red
line would be in the presence of an
activator okay so with an activator it
doesn't take as much of a substitute as
high a substrate concentration to get it
to a higher reaction velocity
so notice let's say at this particular
reaction at this particular substrate
concentration we was out a
without an activator we'd have this
reaction velocity right here right but
with with with the activator we have a
higher reaction velocity at that same
substrate concentration okay so that's
because the activators will get more of
them more of the enzyme into the r-state
right it will stabilize that our stay
and keep it there where as an inhibitor
an inhibitor here right it would require
an even higher substrate concentration
to reach the same reaction velocity
right to get to the same reaction
velocity here you would need to add this
much substrate which is more notice I
try to draw it here but I didn't want to
go too crazy but the activators in the
inhibitors allosteric activators and
inhibitors these things do not change
the v-max so this inhibitor here if I if
I kept drawing it eventually would reach
the v-max at a high enough substrate
concentration okay so that's about it
for for allosteric enzymes I hope that
was helpful and pretty clear keep all
this stuff in mind so that when we talk
about allosteric enzymes later and
pathways particularly I think glycolysis
we'll talk about first
it'll all make sense okay thanks for
watching